so there's speculation
that the name corn has uh something to
do with
coroner like that that it came from so
so the
the the two things i saw was that it was
the the coroner in
kern county or it was children of the
corn
no no none of that that's [ __ ]
horrible this story
all right well now we're now we're
excited i'll just do it real short
me and some of my friends in baker from
back in the day were at this party and
there was two gay guys talking about how
they loved felching each other
okay and the one dude was talking that
he was felting his lover and the guy
[ __ ] all over his face he had a corn
kernel on his tongue okay got it
so that's how it came about so people
that knew the story they were there we
just go
corn and be like shut up derby oh god
damn no no
no no that's funny and that's how the
name came about but when
nobody in the band when when i joined
the band knew about the story i'm like i
told them this story mike and they're
like oh but
it's such a cool name let's just do it
it was like
we named the corn and then our manager
larry was like hell no you cannot name
your band corn but no it's absolutely
not go then we'll name it larry
[Laughter]
don't mean the whole thing behind it was
like
it doesn't matter what you're called it
was like a punk rock thing it's like
[ __ ] we call corn who cares it doesn't i
don't need any mysterious weird [ __ ]
name we made it like that
it was cool because uh philly's like
dude you gotta
write it with a backwards arm like a
little kid would write it so i grabbed
the crayon and i did it with my left
hand and that became the [ __ ]
it was done in two seconds and that's
become that iconic logo
wow and just that's how it all came
together what was that
huh yeah because i mean i've been asked
when i was young was all yeah it's dark
and mysterious but i was like
[ __ ] corn is the dumbest name i've
ever [ __ ] band
but that's cool that's the charm of it
it's like we didn't care i loved
that energy when we were young we didn't
give a [ __ ] about nothing
yeah dude